[Music]
Phillie Eilish was literally walking on
walls 10 the ceiling during her
performance a bad guy on SNL this
weekend from Doug and now thanks to this
video that Justin throw toast we have a
little insight into how she did that and
there you have it the stage itself moves
throughout the performance with the
camera mounted in place
[Music]
it's funny because sometimes you dream
about something and you might write it
down you might tell people and be like
this is what I want you know in my
wildest dream and then I did that and
here et was with Billy just weeks before
the performance she had this to say I'm
actually so excited I I feel like I've
TV TV performances are like a complete
different world yes so terrifying and so
I mean the experiences I've had it's
always been good so yeah I can forward
to it and thanks to her performance
Billy's been introduced to a whole new
audience are you ready for the next
level of superstardom no no I think I am
honestly no I think I I feel like like I
always have been a little bit without
really realizing it your destiny
[Music]
[Applause]